welcome to this video playing st vela
and at least it seems to be you player
and not like that Tim OH phonica guy so
mmm why am I thinking is a human I have
played him two times before in 12 times
which is really impossible check against
them against an engine okay is playing
the the bogo from my own opening that's
transposed to an in zone with nida 30
it's in it it's a rare line but not so
bad but not bad at all so hmm can I do
something crazy yeah let's go let's go G
for its do something crazy him I've got
the g file hooray Bishop age six and
long castles let's try for that yeah I
really feel like doing something
something funky after I had to play some
bloody cheetah in the game before ok he
just gives me the exchange that's a
really generous and let's let's take
let's take that Bishop
check
yeah where is blacks compensation
probably let somewhat insecure King long
term but his King position isn't exactly
great either oh I can take you for now I
think I really should take it and yeah
maybe d5 takes long castles and that
that looks like a crazy continuation ad
is probably also not very good I go F
butts well if he opens it up hmm 92
maybe 92 looks a little bit it looks a
little bit more sane that same
so there may be F three-year cavity for
now it's a full exchange really but a
messy position maybe you can do
something crazy taxi takes d4 also us
also this is one of the soul so take
here ok TX 93 sick on f4 then I mean
queen I Queen the check on edge for
group g3 is got f4 that's a remarkable
idea maybe this one night f2l to have 95
with the temple yeah that's probably
right 93 Queen f2 yeah yeah
ok and here I go FTX Knight takes Queen
F tool that looks at wins so probably
that's let's take this and put all those
pawns in the center check yeah queen of
two trades Queens I think check it's
something that I shouldn't check pairs
on should g2 let's keep try out that
that looks ok
look see one let's try to get that see
porn it would be good night before I
guess I 50 okay I have to go go here
okay forward and rooks e7 going check
the deep on and I guess so don't really
see anything great now
no key some chicks who takes no that's
not going to work and what the night is
just a couple of checks or should know
wow isn't that promoting why isn't this
promoting check I don't know I don't
know
should promote
night is 668 should promote
check
hmm
you of course how you can continue as
new google that says you have to resign
with the Rope down check check
check
um yeah maybe look which will be eight
he's looking for some kind of stalemate
business or so I don't know check
hmm time warning
yeah what is the way to do this probably
check starting with this move check hmm
it's not not so easy Sally if he gets
the pawn it gets the apron check ok not
that easy well it is taking taking some
moves let's say
check check check black forfeits on time
oh there was a super crappy game that
was I mean crappiest room where but
totally unorthodox I really didn't care
much after the last game again against a
cheetah okay bishop he went to g6 yeah
well Luke f7 I thought 95 maybe I think
actually a disposition is probably good
for it the engine disagree it does does
agree again can for the total mess yeah
but now it is it is unclear somehow f3
this is a cool move okay that computer
just take see a bit I couldn't really
bring myself to do it i saw that
something like that I clack OH here
because of f4 I even then 9 a-3 as
possible so Creed III actually just win
I didn't see night at three and I saw
that look this looks entirely messy and
well but this does work and I go back
and it's a rope here it's not it's not
too shabby okay but this also shot when
you reach a check check
yeah I actually hang out a bit too many
trades there with the rook up check so
that it check check really took took a
while check how did you actually get
over this I could take g 60 I didn't
hurt 86 ok been a long session ok thanks
for watching